let's bring it in Senator Tom cotton
he's a Republican from Arkansas he's a
member of the Senate Armed Services
Committee and Senate Select Intel
Committee and he has been isolating just
like the rest of us good morning to you
senator good morning good morning
everyone
all right there's a little bit of a
delay here let's start with what do you
think make of the president's plan to
reopen the country the president's plan
is measured it's judicious it's the
right approach we can't set an arbitrary
deadline we can't have a single plan for
the entire country obviously some parts
of the country have been hit very hard
like New York or Detroit but other parts
of the country especially the rural
parts have seen very few cases at all
and as long as that remains the case I
think it's the right thing to do to
encourage our governor's to begin on a
slow gradual calibrated basis to get
people back to work to get people back
to their normal routines taking
appropriate measures like maintaining
distances at the workplace or in shops
wearing masks and so forth obviously we
have to be prepared for any surge in new
cases as we begin to do that but I think
it's the right approach to begin to get
the economy back on its feet okay let's
talk about the letter that Republicans
sent to the president talking about
funding for the w-h-o I know that now
Democrats are saying that he's violating
the same spending laws that brought
about impeachment they're talking about
impeachment again the president's not
allowed to do this and take away funding
from the whu-oh so in the letter that
the Republicans sent it said basically
we need to just get the leader out of
the w-h-o and then we'll continue
funding here's an excerpt from the
letter that that was set we have lost
faith in director general Tate Tadros
ability to lead the World Health
Organization we understand a value the
vital role that the w-h-o plays around
the world especially in acute
humanitarian settings we recommend that
you condition any future fiscal year
2020 voluntary contributions to the
w-h-o on the resignation of
director-general Tadros
have you heard anything from the
President on that is he gonna recommend
the firing of him well I think the only
way we can have confidence in the w-h-o
the short terms of dr. Ted gross and his
senior team leaves they're going to he
has a well-established reputation for
corruption going back to being a
minister in Ethiopia when China was
handing out bribes there as part of
their belton road initiative and going
back to the earliest days of this
pandemic the w-h-o under his leadership
seemed to prioritize political
correctness and sucking up to China not
trying to focus on what their name calls
for which is world health right there's
been a problem we allow China to get
dominance in there dating back to
administrations and we found ourselves
caught meanwhile let's talk about China
we watched Japan make a national
movement to pull manufacturing out we've
seen statements from the UK and France
showing how upset they are with the lack
of transparency with this whole pandemic
that has poisoned 180 countries so right
now with their economy shrunk at 7% what
Senator Tom cotton do you think should
be the next step as more and more
focuses on that lab in Wuhan that you
talked about in January where you
thought this thing could have emanated
from yeah Brian the circumstantial
evidence which I began to cite in
January stacking up pretty quickly that
this virus may have originated in those
labs in Wuhan we knew from the very
beginning that the Chinese Communist
Party's front story about the food
market was probably wrong for one it
appears that they don't even sell the
kind of bats at that market from which
this virus originated into Chinese
scientists in an authoritative study as
early as January found that about a
third of the early cases had no contact
with the food market whatsoever we know
that China has a very sloppy history of
laboratory safety some of our own
diplomats at the embassies in China went
to these labs as far back as two years
ago and said the shape the practices
there were very alarming and you can see
how the Chinese Communist Party has
continued to lie about this from the
very beginning as if they have something
to cover up if that's the case it really
is the biggest the cost list the most
deadly cover-up in the history of
mankind no kiddin senator let me ask you
about this
you know a lot of people wound up with
$1,200 directly deposited in their
accounts over the last week or so but
because there's been such conflicting
signals from Washington about you know
the SBA has small business
administration has run out of money
right now for these loans and people
don't know exactly what the next step is
until the Senate does something and
Congress does something but regarding
just those checks that people have
gotten I oddly it seems like there's a
lot of misinformation I had two people
asked me they said okay that 1,200 bucks
I've got to pay it back next year right
and I said no you get to keep that this
is not a group this is not a loan or
anything like that it's to stimulate the
economy and to get you to buy groceries
and everything like that right yeah
that's exactly right for anyone making
less than $75,000 or any family making
less than $150,000 it's $1,200 a person
$500 per child those are simply payments
designed to help our people get through
the worst of this crisis it doesn't have
to be paid back in the future it's
designed to make sure that you can put
food on the table at the end of the week
that you can pay the bills and keep a
roof over your kid's head at the end of
the month as we get through the worst of
this crisis hopefully sooner rather than
later
those checks are designed as an
emergency lifeline for our families
senator our anchor and friend bret baier
who lives in DC is talking to these
lawmakers on both sides left and right
and he said that they're discussing a
possible payback for China and one path
could be suing China class-action
lawsuit for their negligence in this is
that possible yeah Ainsley with
legislation I've introduced with Dan
Crenshaw will be possible it amends the
foreign Sovereign Sovereign Immunities
Act which allows foreign officials to be
sued in our courts this is exactly what
Congress did for the victims of 9/11 we
should do it for the victims of this
pandemic that's just one step that we
can take there's a lot of other things
we can do as well for instance revoking
Chinese visas for the kids of Chinese
oligarchs who are studying an advanced
scientific computer science and other
kinds of technological fields they go
back to the United States
we're simply bringing back more of
manufacturing capacity so we create jobs
here jobs they're going to help ensure
our safety and our health in the future
senator I'm gonna put you in a difficult
position I'll put you in the White House
for a second the president's in a tough
spot he's close to doing a deal with the
other economic behemoth and that's China
at the same time he knows they're
responsible at the same time he knows
currently we have a lot of our
manufacturing there and a lot of our PPE
we need to come out of there how do you
do this gradually in a way that's
diplomatically savvy and not emotional
at a time like this we're currently we
are interlocked
yeah Brian sadly we're in the situation
where China does have the market
cornered on things like masks and gloves
and other medical supplies even on some
of the components for testing and just
this week it was reported that China is
withholding a lot of that medical
equipment from the United States on
spurious grounds so obviously we don't
want to rush into this change we don't
want to say that we're gonna put import
bans on Chinese goods in place next week
because we have to have those goods now
to protect our doctors and our nurses
and all the people who are struggling
with this virus but we also have to
begin to plan for how we're not going to
be dependent on China in the future
because this cannot be allowed to ever
happen again to make our stuff alright
thank you very much senator thank you
for joining us from the DC thank you all